yeah you want to put this in the
baguettes put this in the beginning okay
so yeah so I ended up going on Amazon
you know how people do thumbnails with
like a whole bunch of like stacks of
$10,000 the stock trading guy is like I
made all these money before I took a
poop in the morning I got some prop
money from Amazon so I might end up
using that in a thumbnail you shouldn't
have told him it was prop money oh yeah
just I'm just using $10,000 as a coaster
oh well okay well anyway I'm going to be
using $10,000 as a coaster well welcome
back everyone this is the fourth so with
that said you guys thank you so much for
watching yeah so Ramsey as being a bad I
wish you could see what's going on
off-camera got this this new cat it's
like this vegan leather and it was a
really nice couch and of course Ramsay
decides to jump on the couch and then
you know how cats do the thing where
they go on something gear with their
paws he started doing down on the couch
it's gonna leave these little holes in
the cat I'm like no let me tell you that
couch is so nice and that's one of the I
said that was probably one of the nicest
couches I've the design it's crazy I'm
super good but I have some holes in the
armrest no I just can't have him destroy
the couch he could he could destroy the
the rug underneath the ottoman is
something I don't want to destroy that
too but he's doing that oh wait here he
is oh hey I don't know if you see him on
now you can't see me we'll see okay
anyway yeah you could kind of see him
there he's a troublemaker right now
anyways uh welcome back to the fourth
ever episode of the iced coffee hour
with Graham Stefan thanks and yeah mg
and Ramsey oh yeah we just want to thank
everyone for the first three episodes
everyone's been really supportive of
them and we're over like 50,000 views
between all three of them which is
pretty cool Z yes and we got monetized
too that means so you guys can watch ads
in this video exactly how exciting is
that so we should share how much we've
made so far okay so we've made $72 that
leads you to our Lau so that's a few
days all right
no 7e do but what you have to consider
how much work went into that I would say
from actually filming the episodes I
would say 20 minutes of prep work an
hour of filming
Christine's one took that was an entire
night from like 8 p.m. to midnight yeah
of doing that plus editing editing that
one don't really took me like 5 hours to
edit it's less yeah we'll probably make
it like 5 dollars an hour for doing this
right now so that's why you got to get
your two free stocks from weeble that's
why you have to click on the ads watch
them all the way through we can't tell
them do that but why you're not supposed
to tell people to watch the ads and
watch them all the way so ok
so don't do that no don't do that guys
don't don't get your two free stocks
down below in the description we've all
and everyone was saying there was issues
with seeing it on Google podcast I will
podcast Spotify and stuff like that um
it'll be fixed they're already all up
there this one will be up there
regularly scheduled time 9:00 a.m.
Sunday so I don't know which camera to
look into which do I look into this one
probably look into I'm looking in that
one I'll look in this one ok ok I call
so yeah that's really exciting you'll
monetize 72 dollars in the bank mmm
gonna get reinvested soon we're getting
some new audio equipment yeah so look
out for that yeah it's gonna sound way
better philosophy honestly when it comes
to that I know you want to go all out
with audio we should only spend the
money that the podcast makes I'm down if
the podcast makes a grand spend a
thousand if it makes two thousand spend
to that just reinvest it keep
reinvesting it back but we should we
should take a line of credit out because
I think I think it really just makes
sense to get the some good stuff right
in the beginning we could pay for it
then in the future winner yeah with the
podcast do that but yeah that's that's
pretty exciting also Graham we didn't
ever address this on the podcast but 2
million subscribers on the main channel
did we not I thought we did we did okay
100,000 on the second channel yeah Wow
and like 9k on the podcast channel it'll
be 10 maybe I don't know if it's gonna
be 10 by the time this bus they'll
probably be at like 85 9 it's already at
9
yeah we're at 9 Wow very exciting stuff
thanks thanks guys if you're watching
this by the way and you're not already
subscribed make sure to subscribe
because the sad thing is this video is
gonna get more views than we're gonna
have subscribers that's a problem that
means people are watching and they're
not subscribed but yeah
so but yeah pretty cool stuff right
there and then also we also want to know
what kind of content you guys want to
see in here because that's been
something that Graham and I have been
really curious about do you want to see
more finance and business related like
conversation or do you want to see like
every day just kind of talking about our
lives talking about what's going on our
plans for the future and stuff like that
and then bits and pieces of Finance like
if there's any news or anything but just
really let us know any comments that
criticism always always welcome and also
we've responded to every single comment
on the podcast so far we're all caught
up and most comments in the future we'll
get responded to yeah Jack Jack is gonna
be answering a lot of them I pop on
every now and then with a video post I'm
always there mm-hmm so and lastly some
of the top comments had to do with my
posture and me not having a beverage
this time I have two beverages to make
up for my previous lack of beverages go
and I will be working on my posture this
entire podcast what does that say about
my posture was your posture really that
is good man is it good yeah really good
mine just like my neck cranes because I
forgot a long torso when I could be it
yeah so something that's really really
funny that I saw in the news people are
throwing away their stimulus checks on
accident Oh accident I was about to say
dude there's no way they're doing that
on purpose no it was a it was a article
post in NBC News people are literally
throwing them out well they just don't
know I've almost thrown away checks uh
farmers insurance is sometimes emulate
refund checks for things and I just
think it's spam I just think it's like
oh another one of these I'm sure I
probably throwing out checks at some
point know people are literally so the
recent round of stimulus has been
provided in the form of prepaid debit
card yeah and like the way that they
issue them they don't say anything of it
being like from like you know the
government anything no because then
people steal off the mailbox yeah
exactly so people have literally been
throwing them away I mean it's not
surprising but yeah there's been a lot
of theft for stimulus checks people
going through mailboxes stealing
stimulus another checks debit cards
prepaid debit cards it's just odd though
that they would provide it in a form of
debit cards because like there are so
many things that you can't buy with
debit like what about people like trying
to pay their rent and stuff like that I
mean there's probably ways there are
ways around it
their ways around paying your rent with
it with a debit card you can go and use
your debit card - I believe get a money
order and then you could use the money
order it's it's for people that don't
either have social security numbers or
how the bank accounts that's that's
really what it's meant for what about
the people that want to invest the money
- like you said that there was this
article about this person that invested
their stimulus money bring that up talk
about it it's a funny one she was 22
from Louisville Kentucky she basically
said her stimulus was free money so she
may as well as just you may as well just
play around with it and said that
investing is like the easiest thing
she's ever made but but she's been doing
well so far like she's she's almost
tripled her money and didn't she do like
leveraged oil yeah she invested in two
time leveraged oil ETFs and United of
course between the two she's more almost
tripled her money yeah yes sir and she
says you could make a lot of money in
with no effort whatsoever just investing
that's good double oil ETFs could be
spent on you know very worse things so
honestly I agree with that I think if we
look at the bigger picture here a lot of
people I don't want to see a lot of you
because I don't know the statistics
behind it but I'm sure some of the
stimulus money has been wasted on things
that just people don't need I'm sure a
lot of it goes towards necessities and
bills but I'm sure there's a portion of
people out there who's just like let me
get a TV or let me get something like
that and in a way that actually I take
that back in a way the stimulus was
supposed to be for buying things like
that yeah but wasn't it from like small
family ran businesses was that what they
were they were trying to promote fast
yes yes and no I mean at the end of the
day they want the money going back into
the economy and having the money
circulating the economy in the form of
consumer spending is better for the
economy than going and investing yeah
that's if I got my stimulus which I
didn't because I'm a dependent and I'm
in college yeah I would definitely
invest it that's I mean yeah there's
nothing that really well I mean you're
dependent on people smashing like that
exactly it's a smash lifeline by the
each about but no and yeah but no
seriously I mean if someone goes and
buys a TV TV with that it's it is good
for the economy to buy a TV then smart
thing would be
to invest I would say yeah the smart
thing would be two of us so she did the
smart thing she invested mm-hmm honey if
you watch the channel yeah she saw the
channel because I I made a video on how
to spend your small hundred dollar
stimulus check and I went through and I
said like here's what you should do with
it if you have bills you have
necessities like if this is extra money
for you to time don't read it leopard
oil ETF no I United no but for real and
I mentioned like investing is a good use
of the stimulus Chen if you already have
everything covered and this is just
bonus money so maybe she watch the
channel she's like listen to time
leverage oil ETFs make sense yeah yeah
it will fuel the economy definitely more
than buying stocks the person I just
bought a guitar I bought a Stratocaster
the person I bought the guitar from
bought a new Stratocaster with their
stimulus money Wow so here we go it's
it's going back Nick I mean that's the
most important thing it's going back to
the exactly I just thought that was
funny people were literally throwing
away like $1,200 catching up on the week
is there anything that you wanted to
discuss anything cool happened in your
life between you know last podcast and
now yeah I think a lot of people didn't
want me to talk strictly about
investments so I'll talk about non
investment things got to scooters so
yeah that's it that was it that was a
cool thing been waiting for awhile and
these scooters so I went on Amazon you
know the line Birds yes yeah yeah Amazon
sells another version of that that's way
cheaper they're like 280 to 300 bucks
made in China something like that I
don't know where they're made but anyway
so I got two scooters so now instead of
like driving somewhere doing like a you
know 30 minute walk or something you
could scooter just anywhere you want so
that's been a lot of fun it's just you
end up saving a lot of money on on
parking because sometimes like a lot of
places too because you don't want to
walk like 30 minutes but if you're gonna
drive there's no free party like free
parking is hard to find or it's like you
know a few dollars for parking you could
take these little scooters down there
and it's free it doesn't worry about
parking yeah I I've been in the market
for a scooter recently and Grahm buying
this scooter it really makes me want to
buy one I so far I've been really happy
with it we'll see a lot of people have
said the scooters are broke
after a few weeks so I want to give it a
few weeks to give my final
recommendation on the scooter but so far
so good
well if you guys see some guy driving
like a lunatic a scooter and the streets
of LA and neon green scooter just know
it's probably grams probably me if
because it's the only neon green one
like it's it's literally it's like a
highlighter green is that going man
what's up why'd you pick that go
attaches the brake callipers of the test
oh of course of course so I thought that
was just kind of cool all right
but yeah so what else besides that I
think that's that's about that's that's
about it my everything else is pretty
boring it's exciting your furniture here
we're sitting in a new oh yeah we got
that we got this set up here yeah so so
this may or may not be the setup for the
future podcast episode so let us know if
you like it I like it yeah yeah I got to
get something on this wall right here
yeah that's what that's what I'd be
looking Aquarius it's thinking about it
it's unfortunately there's an arch right
behind this you end up losing the arch
but I do think an aquarium might look
really cool the other issues its if we
film a podcaster you get a horrible
reflection and getting the lighting of
the aquarium correct with us in front it
would be difficult but it's a
consideration right right here I
actually think it eat it yeah open I
can't do it I think this is imagined on
the new table I just
what do you think the future is gonna be
like do you think people are gonna be
going to movies because AMC announced
that they're gonna reopen a lot of a
theater zin this month yeah I saw that
so it's gonna be half capacity and
they're gonna require people to wear
face masks I don't know I think it would
be fun to see the occasional movie I
think if there's a big movie that's
coming out a quiet place to I would love
to go and see that in a theater would
love to which one is the quiet place
John Krasinski oh I just didn't wanna
sound stupid yeah yeah that's the first
one I did I loved it and I was actually
really looking forward to the second one
in the movie theater because it's like
you don't get that same experience if
you're watching it from a TV or from a
computer you have to be in a movie
yeah so there is that experience to it
that I think will always be there but I
can't imagine them being as prevalent as
they are now hmm yeah I don't think so I
think that YouTube's kind of taking over
and I think that's the same for like
mainstream media in like television - I
think that people are just gonna start
watching YouTube and that's where
everything's gonna come from they
already have and a lot of YouTube
content is turning out like a movie like
like people are really making these
little films that are 20 to 40 minutes
long that you could really just binge
and they're really good Shane Dawson did
a great so holds all of Shane Dawson
series I think have been phenomenal I
really like them and it is like watching
them it's like watching a Lord of the
Rings trilogy except that Shane Dawson
Jeffrey star it's like it's really good
and I think as long as you have a good
TV a good surround system it's like 50
60 percent of the same thing of a movie
theater for no cost
yeah yeah I'd agree it's it's
interesting to think like where exactly
we're headed in the future is TV and
like you know movies because I don't go
to the movies as is but is it just gonna
be completely like obsolete know what's
gonna happen you know what movies maybe
at some point I think it's gonna shift
online but what the issue that that I'm
seeing is that like years ago it used to
be like you would have Netflix for
anything you wanted to watch but then
they had some licensing issues and then
you know some of the contents on Hulu
and then you know Disney started up
their own thing and then HBO is doing
their own thing and then you have
YouTube so what started off is like one
centralized place for everything Netflix
now you have to subscribe to like
multiple different things it's turning
out to be like TV channels again like
they've got away from TV channels
Netflix and now it's going back to like
you have to subscribe to all these
different things if you want all the
content so you know that's why I still
like YouTube seems like a lot of stuff
is still just YouTube based yeah yeah I
think YouTube's great and I think that
one of the reasons why it's so
successful is because so many people are
putting so much content out there that
you can just pick like from a larger
selection yeah you know what I mean I
agree with that I like the the how-to
based nature of YouTube like like all
the stuff like how do I do something
I'll look it up on YouTube like I had an
issue with Photoshop the other day and I
just I you tubed it and some dude was
like had the same issue and then post
on YouTube I'm like how did how is this
person like I would never think to
myself oh I had this issue I when you
press command why it subdues the colors
and so it like I typed in like how to
make color come back Photoshop like some
dude or you did yeah but it probably had
like thousands of views yeah oh yeah
yeah it's just goes to show you like
little tiny things like that I'm sure
he's making money from this it's good
yeah find a problem and solve it do you
think do you know the movie obviously
you know but have you seen the movie
wall-e a while ago yeah do you remember
how in the movie everyone was in like
these pods and everyone was like super
obese and they were like going around
they didn't have like real human
connections and stuff like that kind of
yeah do you think that like in the
future I'm talking like a hundred years
from now
now we're gonna kind of go into like a
completely like we're gonna like in for
a massive change I don't know it's it's
very much like the matrix where they can
plug you in I think a lot of people
would do that I think of people who are
like I think a lot of people are just
suffering they're not happy with their
lives there's no way to change it for
them and they've lost hope and I think
for a lot of people to be able to plug
themselves into something and have an
entirely new reality new experience they
would do it I think a lot of people do I
think that's also a reason why not
everybody but I think video games could
be very addicting because people want to
immerse themselves in this other reality
where they could be whatever they want
so I do think that if something like
that were to come about it would be a
real thing the issue comes then with
with you know sustaining your lifestyle
like where do you live where does the
money come from how do you pay for that
so there's got to be some sort of
existence in reality but but assuming
that someone could save up enough money
and basically say I'm gonna live in a in
a shack somewhere I'm gonna park my RV
in the desert I got enough to live they
could plug themselves in for like you
know six days out of seven mm-hmm you
know I don't think it's gonna be
indefinite because there's there's got
to be someone watching over you to make
sure like you eats and stuff like that I
don't think that's going to I don't
think you could plug yourself into a
system and then have like a drip thing
for your food and just be like for years
on end without like waking up from that
so yeah things can't manage
I think the experience will be
eventually so immersive that you
wouldn't be able to tell the difference
between reality and a you know an
illusion that's crazy I think that
stuff's gonna get pretty popular too
yeah like it do you think if you had the
opportunity to virtually live the best
possible life that you could live would
you want to do that no because I would
be firstly I feel like I'm living my
best reality currently and I would be
too afraid of doing I just wouldn't want
to get like everything's going really
well I wouldn't want to know I wouldn't
do it huh since you say that you think
you're living your best reality I was
wondering do you have like obviously
it's a stupid question but like do you
have any long-term goals that you still
haven't fulfilled because you've been so
successful this past ten years that I
feel like you've probably assigned
yourself plenty of goals and you just
keep on achieving them it's just things
I want to do the aquarium is a big one I
want to set up the aquarium that's like
a short-term thing like I'm sure that
you could like give yourself short-term
goals like Oh from a video that performs
travel travel is something I want to do
a van life think would be fun I don't
know about boat boat life might be kind
of fun too but I think van life
traveling is something is that's a
long-term goal of mine I don't know if a
lot of people ask to evolve write a book
I don't know if I'll write a book at
some point it just seems like a tedious
thing to do at this point yeah so since
you don't I mean you have goals but what
do you think my goal should be if you
were in my shoes right now what's the
what's the course of action you would
take everyone's different you know I
can't I can't answer that for you what's
you want what do you want because a lot
of people don't don't want what I want
right but I'm just yeah I'm just curious
if you were in my shoes would you drop
out of college yes immediately yes and
then what would you do I would work for
the Graham Stefan show that's what I do
for real I think that I think is way
more potential going out on your own
like like what I see is that there's
this just there's not that much upside
for for school and I think there's an
opportunity that you have the advantage
to take it you could you could go for
the worst-case scenario is not really
that bad I think a lot of employers are
now realizing that the value of a
college education is not what it used to
be
I think a lot of employers would value
the fact that you took a risk and you
went off and pursued your own thing and
did not finish school because you saw an
opportunity and you went for it I think
that says a lot about someone I think
your 20s or the the best time that you
could just hone in on work and make a
name for yourself I just think in your
20s the best time you got everything -
so hone in on the gram Stefon show I
think so and everything I'm biased so
obviously I'm saying that because I mean
it benefits me to write but I think you
in the same way can can ride that same
wave but just continue editing the
videos and coming up I think yeah coming
up with other ideas like the the witch
mile call it the administer the
mentorship that was that was your that
was your running yeah I mean you really
built that up
I could I could not have done that
without you so that was a good example
of something where you had an idea and
that idea turned into a reality within
like two months yeah so just come up
with more stuff I think more ideas like
that and then it's figuring out how to
grow it it's not so much like like the
mentorship group by the way link down
below in the description for anyone who
wants to do that we got a really good
start but then it became this bottleneck
of growing it and how do we expand it
and that's the point where I feel like
need some improvement and I'm leaving
this up to you so I'm really trying my
best not to get involved now I'm
focusing on the main channel like you
know everything else this is you right
so I feel like you had this idea you
grew it and now it's about taking it to
the next step but I feel like it's it's
confined because there's something
holding him back and I'm not sure if
it's if it's if it's me if it's the if
it's the promotion of the I'm not sure
what it is but there's something that's
limiting the growth what is that I would
place more of your effort on that what's
holding it back how can that be better
instead and I love the podcast right but
I feel like it became a thing and you're
like okay let's go to this over here the
podcast the issues that we've got this
thing that's growing it's right well
link down below in the description but
we could grow that we could we could
five-time that in six months I mean
literally we could take that five times
what it is now which by the way is a
good a good it's in the description guys
yeah it's in the strip waiter but
a good idea to get in now because right
now I mean our zoom calls maybe have 20
people in them so you get one-on-one
time whereas in the future you know
obviously as it grows you know we'll
still make time for everybody but still
that's the advantage of now but that's
what I'm saying it's like there's a way
to grow these things to the next level
mm-hmm like when I first started the
channel it was it was going to three
videos a week instead of two and opping
the production quality spending more
time on I feel like it's there but it's
just you got to grow it you know I love
the podcast but put more effort into
that I think it's about growing those
ideas interesting yeah well thank you
appreciate that you're welcome
link down below in the description mmm
one more thing I want to mention
complacency it's really bad I think I
think with the the mentorship group
gotten a little complacent with that
yeah yeah I would agree too because I've
like tons of spread cheating and stuff I
need to do and sometimes I just like
fall back on that yeah but I hired
someone else out to do it but it
complacent it that's the worst spot to
be in because the issue that I feel is
that you you have no no pressing factor
on anything so you don't think I have
the the drive or that I think you have
the drive but there is no push like for
me a lot of my drive like when I when I
bought one of my properties I had no
money in the bank after buying it and
renovating it like nothing and they did
that multiple times but that was the
best motivation for me to be like okay
now I got to make money how am I gonna
make money I'm gonna work even harder as
a real estate agent and then the end of
the year would come around
I'd buy another property spend every
dollar I had like I would have a few
thousand dollars sitting and checking
out that was it everything else was in a
property but that was really good
motivation you do get a bit complacent
when you have more money in the bank
account you kind of lose that ya
motivation no that makes sense I would
hate like I don't want to redirect or
like blame the fact of being a student
and working you know with you at the
same time but I I'm gonna be completely
honest like I do take relaxation time
like like at night I don't really like
working right before I go to bed so
right before I go to like I don't like
editing a video and then closing my
laptop and going to bed all the time
like that's something like especially if
I've been working all day it's hard to
just like close it like I want at least
like or maybe
like around an hour or so of just like
you know unwind and just like relax
that's fair
doesn't mean you can't wake up even
earlier and start the next day that's
hot
I will tell you though if you drop out
of school dad is that's your motivation
right there probably but yeah you're
gonna be so nervous gonna be so scared
about screwing it up that you're gonna
make sure you don't screw it up
yeah but also at the same time I just
took my last final yesterday so I won't
be juggling school and work at the same
time we'll see how it goes you're not
gonna have that you're not gonna have
that debt that fear of just like prove
me wrong if this next podcast okay fair
enough we'll see yeah fair enough
let's see did you know that Carol
Baskins just acquired Joe exotics just
on what do you think about that man saw
that 16 acres yeah you know what the
thing is she got a better lawyer dad
that's all it comes down to I think was
stuff like it well in my opinion I mean
Joe basically admitted to copying her
and redirecting traffic and confusing
its visitors you know I get where she's
coming from she had a good lawyer
go and fight for this and she won so as
unfortunate as I feel for Joe because I
mean the entire series really it seems
like symbolize with Joe like you feel
bad for me you're part of his journey
and a part of Carole's journey it's his
journey I bet if they made it from the
point of view of Carol by asking people
would hate Joe exotic we hate him yeah
but they made it from his real likable
guy um but at the end of the day he was
she was caught in the wrong do you think
the cat think listen the cat over here
it keeps scratching at the furnace it
doesn't it's gotta stop yeah gotta get
him to stop you can't do that okay
are you team Joe I would say I'm team
Joe but it's it's hard to say between
the two cuz they both got a point that
both got a side I watched the first like
three episodes couldn't watch any more I
liked it I don't know man it just didn't
really captivate me now first few
episodes were good and it was a little
crazy and stuff but it just wasn't my
kind of show fair enough and
and yeah I was I was team Joe I was
totally team Joe and it frustrated me
when I learned she had gotten his his
like whole thing his whole zoo I know
yeah but I'm curious to see what she'll
do with it and they'll leave it may be
season to him it seems like a lot of
there's a season to maybe I don't know
it seems like a lot of people are on
Joe's side like I'm a vast majority of
the people on the show is made from
Joe's perspective but why if there's but
still if there's so many people like
eighty percent on Joe's side how is
nothing being done about it I'll do it
man
don't go to jail since we're on the
topic of animals yeah what's up with
these Hornets why have you been what
what's up with them I don't know it came
up front page of Reddit I read it I
thought it was funny so I mentioned
there's nothing that just sounds more
terrible than Turin Hornets put together
its I don't know if you could say the M
word on you - I don't know yeah they
they YouTube transcribe everything the
video so they know every single word
that you're saying
okay well Hornets Hornets yeah M Hornets
just sounds absolutely terrible they
have made 50 people per year in Japan
become deceased and there are two inches
long see how I avoided the K word yeah
look at that two inches and they have
officially entered the United States
officially I love that officially so
watch out guys okay you they officially
they're in the United States watch
everyone okay for these Hornets Wow
alright so we're gonna move on to the
Gmail question segment I'm 15 I'm from
Australia cool yeah so at first I wanted
to be a marine biologist I'd say that
was big when I was like 7th 8th grade
marine biologist and then after that I
wanted to be a drummer like a
professional drummer in a band or a
session drummer and then I thought wait
a second they don't make a lot of money
so then I wanted to be an investment
banker but then I realized well
you know there's a lot of schooling
involved that a lot of hours and then
right after that I became a real estate
agent I became what I wanted to be but
it wasn't what I originally wanted to be
as a kid it was a marine biologist was
was first yeah okay when I was a kid I
wanted to be a firefighter and then when
I grow when I grew older I wanted to be
a real estate appraiser and that's
pretty much it yeah but your dad does
real estate at Bridge my dad's a real
estate otherwise for a kid to be like
I'm gonna be a real thing oh yeah I
would yeah where did you get that yeah
anyways that guy was 15 yeah I know he
did yeah he said he was 50 I did not
sound like that when I was 15 20 I don't
sound like that now yeah
Sammy props he's got a good narration
voice yeah he really does
it's got a cool accent - he's from
Tasmania hmm hey grandma Jack this is
Chris here I had a quick question about
Amazon affiliate commissions I know
recently Amazon cut their affiliate rate
and I was wondering how it's affecting
Graham with his own Amazon store that he
has thanks guys appreciate it yeah
really yeah good question really not at
all
Amazon affiliates for me makes up such a
small percentage I mean it really it
compared to everything else it's so it's
small compared to you know even I
remember my first entire year doing
Amazon affiliates I think was like I
made $100 a month on that total my first
year of doing it so it wasn't much so no
it's not affecting it's not affecting us
sir or hmm
I've always wondered what if you just
set up an Amazon affiliate store and
then whenever you were planning on
already buying something on Amazon just
adding it to your store and then buying
it off of yourself I don't think it
applies to yourself but I'm sure if you
had someone else used to buy it through
your link maybe I don't know it seems
like that like a pain to do that because
if so it's it's such a small percentage
like sometimes it's like 50 cents you'll
get on something or sometimes it could
be like a few dollars I don't know how
much that's really worth it but if
you're buying something really nice off
of Amazon like a
potentially everything but then you're
also taxed on that money that you're
getting from Amazon so it's like even
though you might make like six box
paying tax on that after tax it's like
three it's really worth you know I don't
know maybe it is would you ever get a
tattoo
no no why not I just I just don't want
to put something permanent on me like
that you know as a kid I really wanted
like I thought it was so cool like like
I wanted a pirate tattoo and I was like
ate like an anchor ya know like a skull
and crossbones I thought that'd make a
really cool thing to do and I used to
have these like you know fake tattoos
other otherwise now I'm just personally
about it and not a fan of tattoos on me
yeah neither am i I'm not a huge fan of
tattoos I couldn't see myself ever
getting a tattoo and then people always
say but what if something like super
significant in your life yawns you know
would you get a tattoo of that I'm like
no no what that was that was what I kind
of thought - it's if something really
significant happens what I get a tattoo
maybe I don't know
sapphire reserve raises the the 7 yeah
exactly
um you know I I just wish that tattoos
were like removable like easily
removable because I think they look cool
like I think having like a full-on
sleeve looks cool but I would love the
ability to be like ok I'm tired of this
snap my fingers and it's gone so you do
it if it weren't permanent obviously I
think it would do it if it were not
permanent if I could just decide like ok
tomorrow all of this is gonna be over
and I'll go back to normal I would be
highly likely to do it so only for a day
maybe a few years or something I believe
ya but whenever you get tired of it just
stamp your fingers is gone but that's
that that's not the point of the tattoo
the tattoo is it's because it's
permanent and I I just don't like
putting anything permanent on me and if
something significant happens like I
would rather like I would rather buy a
watch like like 30th birthday I thought
maybe like it might be a good idea to
buy a Rolex it just being symbolic I'm
always wanted to Rolex and I thought
that would be really cool to get the
watch avoid like a Rolex Daytona I
really wanted one of those and I thought
30th birthday is a good like it's a
milestone and that's something you
passed down to like the next generation
but then I thought
that's kind of silly oldest and best
like that's better to invest I'd rather
invest so I did that instead but you
know anything permit you know big like
dams your birthday present to yourself
investing it yeah what am I gonna do
with a Rolex I mean that's the thing too
it's like what am i it's on your other
hand imagine two hands all my videos
seriously is it I know what's gonna
happen with that I wouldn't never wear
it because it's too nice yeah I'd much
rather just invest it so but I see this
as an investment like you'll spend
$30,000 in a watch that over time might
be worth 40 or 50 like I could've bought
the same watch by the way four years ago
the same watch the zennith Rolex Daytona
stainless steel for like 13 grand and
now they're 30 I don't think you should
view watches as investments like I
wouldn't say that like it just does it
doesn't make sense because it's it's to
gamble e-grants it's got a spray bottle
here see quickly you stop when you put
the spray bottle here you'll be doing
that so you would you would call it an
investment I feel like you can justify
the purchase of a watch just because you
like it and then maybe maybe you
preferring a watch that could maybe
retain its value a little bit more
contrary to watch that just appreciates
a ton hmm like that makes sense but
saying that like I could buy it as an
investment maybe it's the same thing
maybe it is like you could you could buy
a lot of art as an investment that's
quit works I don't know when you meet
people for the first time and they ask
you what do you do what you say to them
hey never tell them YouTube no I never
tell them YouTube no because because
then what happens is you're like oh let
me go what's your YouTube channel what
it was about and then I have to explain
the whole thing and then they look at it
oh wow you have two million subscribe
and then all the videos are how much
money it's it's I would rather than find
it organically so I always tell people
what do you do I'm in a real estate you
just say in realist I'm in real estate
yeah I don't because then if I tell them
I'm a real estate agent the first thing
they ask then is oh how is the market I
don't want to explain to everybody how
them
market is going it's like any parties
you go to real estate agent Oh how's the
market I explain how the market is the
next person what do you do I'm a realist
and how was the market I explain how the
market is I'm in a real estate I feel
like well yeah when you say I'm in real
estate it's like the wealthiest response
it's like vague but also like Oh like
yeah I guess so I'd like to leave it
because I don't like contrary to YouTube
I don't like talking about myself always
getting all hyper I don't like talking
about myself that much and if someone's
asking me a whole bunch of questions
like I just I don't I don't feel like I
hate small talk I guess is really what
it comes down to yeah and it's like the
formalities of like Oh what do you do oh
that's interesting what made you get
into that oh cool
how long have you been doing that for oh
cool how's the market going oh yes let
me tell you about you know my far
long-lost cousin who bought a house and
his whole experience buying a house and
sitting I think I'd rather just you know
not not get into that that's all yeah
it's super difficult for me to do the
same because people would say like like
I'll be like oh I got work or whatever
like what do you do and then I'll be
like well I I created like this program
I added videos like I I mean now I'm
probably wouldn't mention the podcast
$72.00 but yeah it's really really
difficult from the same so I just say
like oh I do like marketing exactly I do
marketing and plus it for me real estate
it's like most of my money goes back
into real estate anyway at the end of
the day you know YouTube real estate it
all goes into real estate so real estate
is is you know you're really the
backbone of everything I wouldn't have
the YouTube channel if it wasn't for
real estate yeah so real estate is
really what I what I you know it kind of
got brought up from I would Sam do you
think you're more of a real estate
expert or a YouTube expert now oh gosh
I want to say that it's 5050 so if
someone's gonna ask for consulting on
one of those two and you would you would
say like that's a tough one goodbye
right now I have more fun talking about
YouTube I would say because you're
making more money I mean yes but it's
also it's like it's it's new and it's
exciting and a lot of its changing and
real estate I think the investing
principles of real estate really seem to
be consistent it's it's it's the same
thing
YouTube I feel like is constantly
evolving and I'm really excited about
talking about it because it's it's
something new real estate for me is
something I've just done now for 12
years in 12 years and YouTube is
something for a few years I'm like I'm
really excited about talking about
something that's new that's exciting
yeah I almost just choked on that oh
this is lemonade by the way for anyone
who's wondering this is a lemonade I
almost just choked on my lemonade and
spat it all over myself and that reminds
me the first time I ever met you in
person I've told you this before but no
one they don't know about it all right
we we met at the O group and then we
walked across the street to this burger
place or this restaurant I ordered a
burger and a water and the first sip I
took my water I spilled it all over
myself and this is the first time I've
ever met Graham and I spilled it all
over like my crotch area region and
Graham saw and we both looked at each
other we both looked at each other in
the eyes and then just like didn't say a
word about it like I just like dumped
probably like a pint of water right
there
we just look at each other and then we
just moved on just ignore it yeah it's
so funny to me that that happened when
you were a kid did you ever do those
things were like you'd be in a room with
an animal and you just like come on you
can it's just me and you here we could
talk all the time I try to talk to
animals oh I still I still talk to
ramsey still talk to him like like he
knows it and I'm like you don't don't I
you know put your paws like it like this
scratch the eye you still talk to him
but like that's like commanding like if
you were just alone in a room with
ramsey would you ever still just bec
come on if you're gonna say something
just say it now I've done that before it
not with it not with Ramsey
I've given up I've given up on cats
cancer too they're they've got a mind of
their own I know he's plotting to take
over the world that's some yeah yeah I'm
not gonna mess with that I'm just gonna
hope he spares me at the point where
cats one day right well everything like
I will be spared
okay but not anymore hmm
and what about like other stuff like
trying to use the force it sounds so
stupid but like on occasion like if I
were sitting here there's a chance small
chance but there's a chance I would
still look at that candle and I would
think I can I can put those flames out
I happy I tried doing that after the
movie Mathilda did you ever see that you
were probably 12 at that sometime
probably younger than that when Matilda
came out which is a classic with Danny
DeVito she was able to move things with
her mind you could go like move that up
and down and she had this magic power I
thought like I could do that that that
was real never happened but never
happened it I don't do that anymore
so now since stores are starting to open
up what do you think is gonna be the
future of our economy with this whole
thing I mean it's not at an end but it's
we're rearing near there near the end
yeah it seems like employers are taking
advantage of their employers ploy ease
coming back it seems to be commonplace
now that a lot of the furloughed
employees are being asked to come back
but with a pay cut and employee employer
is kind of know that like listen they
got you because they're guaranteeing you
job to come back but it's at a 25%
discount do you take it or do you risk
yourself in the job market going back
into the unknown working for someone
else that you're not sure if they're
hiring or not or how long you'll be
unemployed so it seems as though people
are being asked to come back but with a
pay cut that is a bit concerning in a
way you know as far as business is
concerned it saves businesses money it's
not good for people so I think we're
gonna see a comeback but I just think
it's a it's a good excuse for people not
to pay employees as much and not hire as
many to come back I think it's gonna be
a major restructuring that a lot of
employers can have one person do the job
of two and and that one person is doing
the work of two would be happy to come
back because you've got a job to come
back to so I think that's gonna be the
biggest impact I'm just scared like will
this ever happen again since we've
already set precedent that like like
what if we get another disease I think
it not a disease illness I don't know I
really don't know I think if it's severe
enough and it warrants another shutdown
we'll be prepared to know how to handle
that so I think we'll be in a better
position the next time but you know Bill
Gates has said something along the lines
of it's gonna be more common that stuff
like this would happen but but we have
the opportunity now to at least
understand it a little bit better and
know how to prepare for the next time so
I think we'll be in a better position
the next time we'll see also I'm sorry
I've been thinking about this this
entire podcast how do I stand straight
when this is gonna be I don't know I
feel like mine is just probably but it's
probably the camera angle that's making
my posture look better than it is do I
sit like this cuz then I'm like talking
down yeah they're like slouch who cares
who can slosh the final or the only gag
question that I have on this one is um
what was the first person that milked a
cow trying to do I would I would say
that's a good question I would say that
probably seeing calves nursing and
thinking wait a second if I need some
sort of sustenance maybe there's
something to this and if it's safe for a
calf it's probably safe for a human
that's what I probably think I don't
think anyone sitting there looking at
the UH ters be like oh I can milk that I
think it's something visually someone
that sees that so for anyone who's made
it this far we do accept the audio
submissions that we can answer feel free
to send those to Graham Stefan podcast
at gmail.com and we'll answer your
questions there also regarding what kind
of content you all want to see here just
make sure you let us know we'll keep
doing whatever we're doing right now but
if we see that people want to see
something else you know feel free to let
us know and by all means we'll be
willing to like you know make any change
even when it comes to the physical
setting of this podcast oh yeah a lots
gonna be changing I would say over the
next maybe like a month or so two months
and we're taking all of your advice and
critiques into consideration everything
from do you know what we do with guests
to our audio everything we're working to
improve it so just bear with us in the
beginning and it's all just it's all
gonna get better every episode should
hopefully get better than the previous
one we're still learning you know this
is only the fourth episode but we should
be getting better and really
appreciative you guys for listening this
far anything else you wanted to say
before I hit the like button get two
free stocks mentor $200
there's two stocks like button subscribe
anything else I'm missing Instagram
alright guys so with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching and till
next time till next time all right good
enough honestly if this was not as bad
as I thought it was gonna be yeah